ten seconds before we get this thing
kicked off 109 players maximum 150 1840
plus time handicap 30 minutes of bullet
chess here we go double those points
move fast move fast play fast win fast
30 minutes here we go is it gonna start
I am entered I have forgot to enter
before not this time watch out for f2
here we go here we go here we go give me
this little ticker coming your ticker
double those points Oh No
start up please start up okay what do
you do when you're not able to get
paired up here come on this is not the
way you want to start a tournament not
the way you want to start come on give
me you better you can better get points
okay okay here we go we have action can
I get a quick kill to start is my
opponent gonna move oh this could be a
good start
a non mover double those points
give me those points it could happen it
should be in effect after 15 seconds
double the points yes - whoa BEC og
already has here we go here we go been
Koji already has four already has four
is the night gonna move okay I'm gonna
take this Knight and I'm going to try
and jump into that d5 square trying to
jump into d5
can I get in this is a more strategic
approach oh I should have gone there at
my knight now this is a good spot for my
night I'm on this pawn get castled I'm
gonna come to go for what am I gonna go
for I'm gonna kick that night out of
there
I'm gonna kick that night out of there I
don't want to move this pawn my Knights
looking really good on that square isn't
he it's got to be good it's got to be
good I can take this pond to
each file attack I'm still gonna do it
open stuff up open stuff up can I get my
clean in there where are those tricky oh
this is looking pretty good I think well
let's try that one I don't know what no
no no no no that's me oh I should've
realized the Queen the King couldn't
move all you have to do is give check a
knight loves to give check Oh Queen f7 I
was thinking queen h5 none of the above
please none of the above
Knight of 7 or was that f7 I have the
coordinates wrong as usual you know what
I meant okay let's focus on d4 my knight
is gonna go on this little journey
because he likes d4 and he's there and
he's happy I want to get rid of the
knight okay hang on hang on I want to
get rid of that Knight Bishop pin
there goes the night and I've controlled
her d4 for the rest of the game I'm not
going to take the knight until they
force my hand now we want the dark
scripted ships off and work on this
position where we have a good night
versus a bad bad bishop he's a bad man
this guy's a bad man open up the B file
my opponent is coming at me pretty
strong here and that scares me okay well
where do I go now because this this pawn
is awesome he's awesome he is awesome oh
there's a check okay can I get him this
file I got to get out of checks this is
scary a bit too scary I like their
bishop I like their Bishop is this
probably get rolling he might he might
not also I'm not sure what of that move
is even doing I'm not sure what that
move was even doing okay this is scaring
me this is Gary I'm not sure why I did
that I got to take the Queen off somehow
oh man my knight is pathetic what is he
even doing but I gotta get made it mmm I
might get mated police say it's okay
oh man how much I only have five seconds
I got to do pre moves and stuff
Primo's and stuff gonna throw in tricky
night checks three point four seconds is
just not enough
han is gonna get rolling
are we doing all the time
oh my goodness I'm that stupid night I
thought he was I was saying that bishops
a bad bad man oh man he was so much
better than my night all we might get an
on mover yes an on mover more points and
getting showered with points oh the wind
is also taken out of me I don't know why
that happens it just does you have to
believe me
I'm not a liar I didn't mean to do that
I didn't mean to do that
okay a 6 B 5 I don't I'll take a free
night he was free oh he's back to free
oh how can every sign know about that
minor piece tricky nights you might go
down away he's scared he's scared let's
go for Queen trade or a free Queen this
might be resigned time isn't it yeah
it's back to tournament land 3030 2014
24 minutes remain confused right I've
said it before I'm not gonna repeat
myself I'm not gonna repeat myself last
time I played this guy said let's see if
I could confuse ray after all I did I
did end up doing what I did end up
repeating myself tonight
okay pile up on this pond he needs to
fall I don't want to do that though
let's try this let's try this and give
that guy up let's get back here on a
Castle queenside
oh that's not a you Castle queenside
okay let's make this work somehow let's
make it work somehow crash through crash
through is the plan that's check can I
get on these dark squares ah
what a terrible thing to do what a
terrible thing to do oh that's a free
pond my king is terrible terrible you're
gonna have clean trade I guess so I
guess so break down this paunch truck
my bishops are looking good why don't I
take that pond he's been free for how
long okay this is crumbling that knight
is pinned I have to controlled this
there is no pin okay watch out for the
tricky Forks over here for a second
build my center a little bit my bishops
on a nice square oh I could have just
taken the bishop maybe I could still get
him maybe I could still get that guy oh
that's me it's gonna be me
that was a surprise I'll take the
surprises back to chairman forty two
forty two thirty five thirty twenty
twenty Oh Billy Billy 91 d5 no matter
what let's try D five no matter what oh
my goodness they resigned back to
tournament fifty-six thirty five thirty
twenty twenty twenty two minutes twenty
two minutes the Beatles I gotta play
against the Beatles right now the
Beatles
here we go Knight f3 let me do something
else like this open this position up and
queenside castle and play e5 Queen e2 no
Queen f3 I lied I lied on that one
that's what I meant to do in that last
game now we do this hitting the rook
hitting the night trying to open up this
file and I believe it's starting to now
crumble isn't it the rook has to move I
can move the knight and beyond the rook
my queen o my queen was close to dead
right there Wow I wanted to drop back
and hit at h7 I wanted to do that um my
queen you really needs to do something
else she's so bad she's so bad where
she's at right now okay hang on position
Oh take the rook oh that was so free ah
it's been a while since I played in
these tournaments it's been a while if I
could provoke g6 then h4 h5 stuff is
appealing let's let's go for that next
okay you're gonna you're gonna hit my
let's go with this instead no I did the
wrong thing uh why am i law in this
position to get so hoping over here my
rink miking has to run he's got to run
I'm gonna give up my rook I don't care
about him what time is about even come
over here defense stuff please so scary
why am I not okay let's open this up can
I finally open this position up whoa was
that scary Queen trade I love Queen
trades the Queen's are off my rook is
excited about what I'm okay I won like I
could win the King upon endgame okay
that was missed that was missed the King
is cut off and now everything else could
be primo for the rest of the game King
up and then March my pawns back to
tyrant they were down on timer design
one or the other okay
oh is this another game is this gonna be
another win they're at negative twelve
no they're just flying at me with their
H pawn though that's what they're doing
okay so I have a pawn what could I do
with it
it's pin their night there's no h3 now
lost the app they lost their option to
play h3 didn't they if they don't have
an H pawn Queen c7 and then queenside
castle play for what I'm gonna take that
and then this and then jump in here no
matter what I'll discover tricks the
queen is dead she's toast she's toast
should be thrown that check in sooner
where's this King going where is he
going where is he going looking for me
in one take the knight take the knight
he's free and then it's mate
I get the rook otherwise take that rook
okay they get that back Castle get my
rook here doing something it's crashing
through c3b three Oh No
but let's just take that oh I need to do
that it's a little scary square to go to
but this game I felt like it should have
been dead so much sooner should have
been dead so much sooner
okay could I just get this pawn and move
my own on am i doing this is not the
cleanest approach not the cleanest
approach at all give me this pawn give
me this rook now no stalemates whatever
you do do not put your opponent in
stalemate King up King up Queen cuts the
King off and then Ming letting the clock
tick down on time back to tournament 90
70 to 50 48 47 not even halfway there
yet Patriot chess Patriot chess Patriot
chess okay whoa let's take this knight
first probably a bad decision to do that
I don't know if I should have done that
move I'm uh I'm playing this bad I just
go back home is to go back home my Queen
has to go back home Oh terrible things
terrible terrible things okay is the
knight gonna kill me looks a little
scary are they expecting that though are
they expecting that move the sneaky King
move take that night let's establish a
pawn in the center get my knight finally
doing something exciting
get on this file threatening with me
maybe one day can that knight move
what's my age fun doing what does he
think he's doing okay I'm on the Queen
right here check moves
oh that's dropping the farm Queens hit
deadly fork tricky night
okay I just want to smash at that point
okay that's check I feel like I need to
still get off to the king bishop check
whoa it's me
close to me upon us to push this is very
close to me I think I end up mating okay
back to tournament end up mating somehow
110 110 I have eleven ten games in who's
this guy who's this guy why why ves
Smith Laura Smith Maura I need a quick
kill somehow 15-minute warning halfway
point
stay on this diagonal I have something
at my sleeve something is up my sleeve I
want to stay on this diagonal oh no oh
no this pond is gonna get hit let's do
this drop my knight back if Bishop eats
free let's get more development in more
development in b5 okay let's get this in
I'm opposite the Queen and pawn push or
something one day how that part could
have been taken so I'm officially in
gamete mode that night could be taken
but he's not being taken if rook takes I
recapture okay let's I just I'm going to
sack here I just want to open this
position up a bit Oh should I have done
it like that
we get my knight to this Square get the
LightSquared Bishop Soph and then okay
he's free the plan was to get the
LightSquared Bishop Soph and then do
what and then okay get on this diagonal
maybe no on the bishop okay I get my
bishop back I have to watch over f7 but
I'm gonna throw I should have thrown a
track at wreck let's try it this way
let's try it this way get that Queen
back I have a flight square I also have
a eight covered oh that was a free rook
let's come back King position look up
mmm no stalemates no stalemates
no stalemates get my rep out of there
afraid this debate come back home
running a corner bishop there that's
what you do to the bishop to avoid
stalemate 130 130 130 83 laser-beam I
have the sniffles I have the sniffles as
well if you're just joining us I'm
playing with the sniffles castle castle
and then play on the f7 square this is
uh this is a good position I believe in
h4 okay this has to be good break down
this I'm threatening just take as this
pawn is pinned by the bishop it's pinned
by the bishop they're not gonna take
that's a free Park oh that's a fork
though oh I could probably afford to
give that up can i let's just take him
just in case just in case just in case
they're now taking back they're seeing
something they might be seeing a ghost
okay well they end up getting that pawn
back but they're okay now they're in a
giant pin that's prop that's a big
problem
there's no h6 anymore so okay now this
is netting stuff
it's netting stuff Queen f2 no matter
what nope if there was a tape there okay
I guess we're gonna go with this no I
thought the bishop is gonna recapture
rook over
[Music]
hun push all right I could have just
taken that you're just taking that pun
okay now I'm gonna keep this Bishop
right there I get my light square Bishop
working he's doing nothing right now
he's doing nothing and he's close to now
doing something hang on okay
I shouldn't take him what the rook and
offer more exchanges okay drop back give
a check they're down on time back to
Terrell one-fifty one-fifty 103 102 less
than 12 minutes Patriot chessick again
again Patriot chess my night didn't I
had to go home against this guy last
time he threw all my pieces in Reverse
why am i doing that's my pieces what do
they do to me what did they do to me
that I have to keep reacting like that
okay well I'm not so excited about
giving that B file to my poner they're
gonna take that pun why not why not let
me do this I'm on the night it's gotta
be a little annoying right
Queen trade I'm gonna play this out I
have pressure on hang on I don't have to
be careful that well that pawn push a
small improvement I have control over
the only open file only open file and
now I'm gonna pin point f2 f2 is exactly
where I want to be I could have taken
and like been on that but an opposite
color Bishop anything now I'm gonna now
I don't want to do that I could take
with the bishop still throw question
this guy first
and actually that pawns not going so far
now there's back rank mate issues now I
can make some King improvements King
improvements slow King improvements get
my King on g5 and play f5 kind of frozen
my opponent is kind of frozen here so
little by little I inch up that's a past
pond and he's going to keep going all
the way down to e1 and there's nothing
that could be done right nothing that
could be done down on time back to
chairman 170 170 123 less than 10
minutes 10 minute warning confuse ray
okay I think there's an adjustment I
could be making with this mainline okay
now this is getting this is crumbling
here these light squares are being hit
oh oh that was almost a very bad mouse
live Bishop's on these adjacent
diagonals queenside castle that's a free
piece I was gonna go there no matter
what they're downing no they resigned
back to tournament 191 7123 jkw 9
minutes 9 minutes remaining I want to
make use of f8 with my queen night
before I Castle just so I could get to
this g6 square and now I want to move my
knight out of the way I'm welcome to the
dark square bishop exchange and now I
want to get to f4 he's a monster from f4
a monster from f4 ice insist I want to
get that night back to that square he's
making it more difficult I want to do g6
let's try it again they're gaining some
space in the clean side but my knight is
a monster let's keep this closed over
here I want to play okay this because
it's up I'm up a pond can I get on h3
yes I can and I could do this they could
take my knight and be on my clean can do
this however and that's a nasty nasty
pin you could take here and I'm on the
clean with the fork take like this I
don't want to take the rook I want to
play here and look for mate and that's
matin to back determine 210 190 I lose
out on tiebreaks
well no actually yeah cuz I'm a game
behind if it ends up in a tie whoever
have
the next tie break thing they look into
is how many games have you played Bishop
c4 okay Castle pin this Knight and then
attack the knight are they gonna do the
same no they're not so they have some
structural issues let's do this and then
look for some way to open the position
up can we open this up the Nike give
check me back and do clean g4 at some
point thereafter but they're just
dropping a piece now I want to get my
knight working but there's some fork
no.1 on the bishop on that bishop in
this pond still but I really want to
just focus on what I want to get to this
square f6 I'm hitting f6 finally this
rook is in a pin and now we're looking
at f7 I'm also hitting the Queen and
they missed it I'm threatening a mate
until night here to here and that'll be
game over no and that's so fast okay I
get my rook working a little bit that
rook is hit it's with check this is me
and one and then two no matter what
cleaned up to that d8 square they're
gonna resign yes they did
back to tournament two 3192 3190 elvis
elvis
Chesley this Chesley Goes Down
whoa just like that alright he he hit
that resigned button pretty quick there
illness 6 minutes 30 seconds
let's try d4 and c4 and Knight c3
automatically eye Bishop out take the
knight and then just play in the center
no all right build my center
ok my centers built ok now I could play
I have a free hand in the center and I
want to get my light squared Bishop
working I also want to look into this
type of break let me get my knight doing
something more being defended and get my
H pawn working and I have to be careful
these Queen side pawns I could get
rolling very quickly but that is
dropping upon and I mean I could run
away this pawn is being supported and
this
rookies falling yes he is they resigned
back to tournament 262 10 175 5 minutes
remaining
oh no John Madden John Madden is here
this guy always gives me a difficult
fight a difficult fight ok coming at me
there I'm gonna have me there ok I'm
gonna take care mass exchanges that's
how we're gonna have is the night really
gonna play there
it scares me hmm it scares me so much oh
man that scares me
you have a clean check we're gonna have
a clean check the bishops come off and
then to check I got a block with the
pawn pawn push I have to be I have to be
defending like this not fun at all
finally oh my bishop can see grab this
pawn ok for a second I was thinking
there was a knight Fork type of thing
when I get out of that pin I can't touch
this pawn this room upon doing so hard
this pawn is plucked
let me get my queen working ok now this
bishop is awesome isn't he this working
pawn push open this up is the Queen
gonna really go there is she close to
trap she might be she might be close to
trapped think I'm just gonna sacrifice
somehow this seems way too appealing not
to do way too appealing not to do that's
making one threat whoa dr. Turner
almost missed that to 80 to 70 I'm sorry
to 80 to 10 I'm up by 74 minutes
remaining 4 minutes remaining
efore more Sicilian get Knight f3 and
pin this Knight
no he's not really pinned is he here no
matter what structural change I want to
get to this c4 square and this Bishop I
want to work against it work against
that Bishop power on push I just chased
the night away to ask where he wanted to
go
to get out of there cannot deal with
that night on that square so I have to
be careful of this one now let's take
that Oh didn't take they're gonna just
take him back there okay
Oh pump no okay yeah maybe I still could
have done pawn push with Bishop there
and there might have been some clean
trap now this knight is pinned I want to
get rid of this pawn first though don't
I yeah let me just make sure that pawn
is long gone that night out of there I
think I just want to take that night he
needs to go in here Oh positions opening
up pawn takes I play Bishop here and the
pawn is one back can also hit it again
had there had to have been a better way
bishop here's better bishop here with
check nice outpost that might cash in or
not now my knight could find good
squares where might be good square
okay the Queen's are coming off and I
could jump into this efore square very
soon pawn push not long off now long off
is upon push my knight could be right
here just in time to defend my rook is
in a good position I could work on my
King position just be careful about
stalemate no stalemates allowed back to
turn lane 3 to 10 300 250 193 206
they're not pairing me up john madden
again alright let's go here we have
played many times I want to get in this
advance with the tempo they're gonna
give up the e4 pawn no they're not okay
this is going to look a little weird but
I'm going to do it I could do this
advance now the knight can't make use of
that square I want to get my light
square Bishop working finally he is
working okay
let's get my clean up I want to trade
these light-square bishop Soph okay
let's do that let's do this I want to
jump into this square jump into this
square wow that night is way too
dangerous way way too dangerous way too
dangerous
is that night oh my goodness he's way
too dangerous I'm gonna get hit with the
fork I just know it could just feel it
can you feel it I could feel it past
pardon hang on these pawns working
somehow I get these pawns working oh my
goodness is that even a good a choice oh
wait wait wait I could have just come
here with the fork I'm on the bishop and
the Queen and the rook and everything I
want to take the bishop though I don't
care about the rook I care about these
guys the ones that are in my position
okay I'm on this pond how much how much
time do I have give any time stop trying
to get active I should push here okay
that'll come with check is this okay
sneaky move I'm in a pin is that okay
whoa oh I'm in a pin over here I'm down
on time oh my goodness 13 seconds my
opponent had 13 seconds oh I didn't have
I was even close to winning that I
wasn't even close to winning that ah ah
man are they gonna sign the points I
wasn't even close
I was not even close 13 second advantage
oh I was having to defend so much ah man
qubits have been assigned uh first-place
confetti barely
ah not without a John man and he slapped
me around I couldn't I couldn't move I
was like oh if I could have moved my
clean but 13 second advantage I had to
defend too much it was too difficult to
do one to crunch out all those defensive
moves those Knights were just way too
scary
ah 298 280 213 and 206 all right
good games